this ranches it's home to me I grew up
with just an old cow horse that I would
go ride through the pastures and as far
as I wanted to go as far as I can see my
great-great great-grandfather came out
with his family and his son WT and found
this spot in Texas and fell in love with
it and founded the Wagner ranch
but I agree Sam and I have been given
the assignment of selling the ranch and
we've got it on the market for seven
hundred and twenty five million dollars
we've had over 600 inquiries we've
narrowed it down right now to 10 or 15
strong players I think we're nearing the
finish line on this this big sky and
open land it's about the size of Rhode
Island there's very few ranches in
existence in North America that are over
half a million acres I don't think there
is another ranch in North America that's
still in the same family over that
period of time and is of the size and of
this magnitude and of this diversity in
terms of its operation so that's what
makes it unique this is a turnkey
operation so you're getting all of the
livestock you're getting every tractor
harvester there's two main different
family compounds in hundreds of other
buildings all the oil division operating
equipment so you're getting all of that
the oil division operates about 1200
wells there's about thirty five thousand
barrels a month of oil that come out of
this ranch our family has a bunch of
history I mean WT is good friends with
Will Rogers and Will Rogers once
commented that there's an oil rig for
every cow out here Teddy Roosevelt came
out here and went wolf hunting out here
actually
one of the most magical things about the
Wagner ranch is its cowboy history and
it's cowboy legend the Cowboys that are
here they're the real deal it's a unique
property it's a one-of-a-kind there's
the very few ranches that could approach
the size of the Wagner ranch and have
the history of the Wagner I think it's
one of the most exciting opportunities
in ranching history I think it's a shame
that the ranch is for sale
my biggest fear with the ranch selling
is just that all the history will be
lost that somebody will come and develop
it the price is listed at 725
the land the horses the history that's
what you can't buy and it's I think it's
priceless personally
you